what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and as you have read Marvel Studios is
making some massive changes to the phase
5 and phase six release dates some
projects have even been pushed back an
entire year now some of you may have
already heard about the changes to the
release dates but in this video I'll go
over the changes and I want to talk
about how they're not necessarily all
bad but in fact this change is a very
good sign from Marvel Studios and Disney
that they are taking the time to make
sure that these projects are going to be
great this is a great example that
Disney and Marvel are not trying to
stick to a deadline just to stick to the
deadline but they are willing to push it
back to make their projects really
really good rather than just trying to
make the best you can and also stick to
the deadline do whatever you can to make
it as good as it possibly can be before
this release date that is not what
they're trying to do and that is a great
sign there's also a lot of other great
news that comes with this in regards to
San Diego go Comic-Con we are expecting
some really really big announcements
there and the fact that Marvel Studios
is releasing this entire new Phase 5 and
Phase 6 schedule beforehand is a really
great sign and I'll break down how this
is all actually good in this video so if
you're super bummed don't be this is a
great thing for Marvel and also if you
love Marvel be sure to subscribe to the
channel so you don't miss out on any of
the latest videos and also so you can
enter our giveaway to win the PS5 and
Xbox series X and other items we'll talk
about that at the end of the video so of
course if you haven't heard the new
schedule we'll go over that and pretty
much everything changed except for the
marbles the Marvel still has the same
release date that is the next Marvel
movie coming up not show because secret
invasion is about to happen this month
but the Marvels is the next movie and it
still has the exact same release date of
November 10th of 2023. so that stays the
same and secret Invasion stays the same
as well no Disney Plus shows have been
announced to be changing right now from
Marvel Studios they just talked about
their upcoming movies so we are
expecting an update for the release
dates for the Disney Plus show since a
lot of them are TBD right now anyways
and not all is bad about this new
updated schedule because Deadpool
actually got pushed up Deadpool 3 was
originally scheduled to come out on
November 8th of 2024 next year but now
it's coming out on May 3rd of 2024 next
year so Deadpool 3 got pushed up and
this is actually quite interesting
because it seems like they have a lot of
confidence that this movie will get done
even though the writer strike is
happening right now however even due to
that we know that Ryan Reynolds himself
has been personally writing the script
for over three years now probably over
four or five years now so this is very
personal to Ryan obviously now he's in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and the
first two Deadpool movies got off the
ground because of him he made the
character so I'm sure that there's not a
day that goes by where Ryan Reynolds
isn't in some way shape or form working
on the new Deadpool 3 script and they
seem very confident that it's going to
be out before this release date they
even moved it up so super excited for
Deadpool 3 and very glad that it got
pushed up and not pushed back but sadly
everything else did get pushed back and
again we're going to talk about why this
is good but here is the current release
schedule for the upcoming Marvel movies
Captain America 4 with its brand new
title Brave New World is moving from May
3rd of 2024 to July 26th of 2024. so
that has moved a couple of months back
and in turn that has delayed the
Thunderbolt since these movies are
directly connected to each other the
Thunderbolts is now releasing on
December 20th of 2024. now blade was
already kind of up in the air as it was
they have not been having a good time
with blade lately losing the director
losing the writer having the script
being completely redone and a release
date essentially being removed from it
there was a lot going on with it and
honestly a lot of concerns around it but
now we do have another official release
date for it right now it is coming out
on February 4th 13th of 2025 and now the
Fantastic Four has moved again to May
2nd of 2025. now sadly we are getting
our Avengers films pushed back an entire
year Avengers 5 the King Dynasty is
actually going to take the place of The
Secret Wars release date getting pushed
back an entire year it was originally
supposed to release on May 2nd of 2025
but is now releasing on May 1st of 2026
which was the spot that Avengers Secret
Wars was originally supposed to have
coming out a year after the King Dynasty
but unfortunately now Avengers Secret
Wars has been pushed back a little over
a year going from May 1st of 2026 to May
7th of
2027 plus not to mention there has been
a lot of talk recently that Marvel
Studios is discussing making Avengers
Secret Wars a two-part film so that
could mean we could get another Avengers
Secret Wars film part 2 in May of of
2028 but hopefully if they did turn that
movie into a two-parter they wouldn't
wait an entire year to give us the
second part although that is kind of
typical but essentially the entire
Marvel Phase 5 and phase six slate got
pushed back a year the Multiverse Saga
was supposed to end with Avengers Secret
Wars in May of 2026 and now it's ending
in May of 2027. however like I mentioned
this is better because Kevin feige and
Bob Iger are now committed to making
better quality content rather than
pushing out a bunch of quantity and
they're essentially doing what Kevin
feige said that they were going to do
they were going to space things out a
little bit more and produce less and
like I mentioned in the beginning this
is a great sign that Marvel Studios
isn't simply trying to abide to a
timeline rather than being afraid to
push things back because they want to
release something to get the money for
it they want to take the time to make
sure these projects are Done Right which
is why they're okay with these delays
this is also insanely good news for San
Diego Comic-Con because we thought that
a very large portion of the panel would
be dedicated to giving us an update on
the release date schedule for Phase 5
and phase six because we desperately
needed a release date update especially
since Kevin feige had been talking about
spacing things out and possible delays
coming plus the rider strike we really
did need that update and luckily Marvel
Studios gave it to us before sdcc so now
they don't have to take this time at
sdcc and talk about the release date
update because we already have it so
that means they have plenty of time to
talk about other amazing upcoming things
and hopefully one of those major parts
like we've talked about in our past few
videos is the entire reveal of phase six
right now we only have four projects
revealed for phase six Deadpool 3 The
Fantastic Four Avengers the King Dynasty
and Avengers Secret Wars there's a lot
of other exciting projects coming that
we know are already confirmed but we're
looking forward to those that we don't
know are confirmed and we're hoping
Marvel Studios releases the full thing
and throws some surprises in there for
us throws in a movie or a show that was
completely unexpected maybe a mutant or
an X-Men project but this definitely
gives them a lot more time during the
Hall age panel to focus on other things
like phase six and the reveal of the
Fantastic forecast if you didn't catch
our last video it looks like Marvel
Studios is trying to narrow down who
they want for the Fantastic forecast so
they can actually make that announcement
at San Diego Comic-Con next month also
not to mention they are going to have
actors and actresses from movies and
shows come on stage and talk a little
bit about their upcoming projects that's
always a lot of fun so now we have a lot
more time for that as well so the fact
that Marvel Studios is willing to do
this isn't all bad the delay really
comes from a place of wanting these
films to be right before they actually
come out so this is a good thing
especially for those who have been
saying that Marvel Studios hasn't really
been up to the same level they have been
with phase one through three this is
what they're trying to do right now make
sure the quality of everything they
release is good and not rushed and
lately in Phase 4 we have seen rushed
CGI and we don't want to see that plus
like I mentioned it gives us more time
at San Diego Comic-Con to talk about
other awesome things so I'm really glad
they decided to release this beforehand
however one thing we still do need is an
updated release date schedule for the
Disney Plus shows a lot of them we
actually have no idea what their release
date is so hopefully they give that to
us at sdcc or they announce it before as
well but of course if we hear anything
any type of update at all we'll be sure
to do a video about it and keep you up
to date so be sure to subscribe to the
channel and click that notification Bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos and if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 so Marvel
Legends items and some DC items as well
the winner gets to pick one item we pick
a winner at the end of each month we are
also on patreon now doing exclusive
content we have a website we post to
every day and a Discord server if you
want to join we'll link those in the pin
comment down below and you can always
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
me